slaves that had good assumption of allah
because
allah said i am as my slave thinks of me
so then at the time of asking allah to
forgive me
i need to think of allah as one who
right now is going to forgive my every
sin
big and small public and private no
matter
you know how many of them they are i
need to think right now at this minute
and believe that allah is going to
literally
forgive every one time i say
sincerity with such certainty and such
good assumption of allah that allah
you're gonna literally wipe my sleep
clean after this one word i'm gonna say
but we don't you know why we're not ah
he's not really gonna forgive that
we don't really think good of allah and
that's because we don't know him
[Music]
the reminder is that no matter where you
are in life you know you don't know
where you're gonna be tomorrow
you could be feeling amazing one day and
then literally lose your iman like that
right the prophet sent him said that
there will come a time where a person is
a believer in the morning
and at night they're a disbeliever
alaikum brothers and sisters this is t3m
welcome back to the realest podcast in
dania featuring
another realist podcast in the dunya
daryl man we got brother imran here
brother how are you doing i'm very good
at him
so you guys well i'm doing very good
pleasure to be here with you guys
all right bro so rami fired why don't
you guys
go in on what we're gonna say here what
we're gonna be talking about because
my mind has gone completely blank
honestly bro the first thing on my mind
is
i don't know man this is just something
i've always wanted and if i ever spoke
to imran this was the first thing that i
would ask so bismillah
what made you want to start this year
sessions
um so right bro you know what it is
i mentioned this story a few times in a
summarized way so
basically um when i started practicing
the dean i was i came up from a
lifestyle of
music um i was you know hanging around
the guys in the streets it's not like i
was like gangbanging or anything like
that but
you know the music lifestyle brings a
certain kind of crowd
a certain kind of you know companionship
so that's that's the background that i
was coming from so when i
started to practice and come to me as
the dean um
you know my when i used to do music i
used to
kind of have this very conscious style
of music where it was more about waking
people up
sending out a positive message and
that's just kind of how i've always been
i've always wanted to kind of have an
impact
you know on people towards something
that is going to be
beneficial for them so obviously when i
came to the deal and i realized that
dean is the most beneficial thing i
naturally wanted to
share that with people i want people to
have that same element of the deen
um so i volunteered to help out
with a youth program in my masjid and as
i'm volunteering at this youth program
i'm seeing that
the kids that are coming in are the kids
that uh
are already you know in the madrasa you
know they're already kids that are
memorizing quran
and we're preaching to the converting
but i wanted to reach out to people that
came from the lifestyle where i came up
from because i know there was guys on
the blocks that are
taking drugs selling drugs shooting
people up stabbing people up getting
stabbed getting shot there's girls that
are fornicating guys
that are phonic and drinking clubbing
raving and that exists in a muslim
community
but those guys are not interested so
um i sat with the brothers and i said
listen so i have an idea
i said we need to go into the club and
get down
sounds like there was a local club and
it was used to be
like popping from that angle and uh i
was like let's go
and uh let's let's go inside and give
that one to the people
so one of the brothers he was the imam
of the mississippi was there with us
he said i want you to just imagine the
imam
in the club calling all these girls and
guys
uh i said yeah you know what i actually
felt like that was actually
what i did and of course later i learned
that of course when you're when you're
getting that way you don't give down
anyway when you put your own emmanuel
because going to a club you know you're
gonna end up
having doubt give them to your assault
so you know you can't you can't
uh like two wrongs don't make it right
so obviously i really like a terrible
idea but but that concept and that
thought of wanting to reach out these
people
um who are not coming to the masjid who
are not seeing the posters for the
events
of i always wanted that was always in my
mind
about two years later i lost he gave me
the idea
he uh gave me the toffee to come up with
the idea
of setting up a youtube channel a
youtube channel
where actually it was even before
youtube i was actually on using facebook
primarily
um because i saw that facebook was a
platform
where i could be in touch with the drug
dealers and i could be in touch with the
fornicators and the foreign cultures
and and the guys in the clubs and the
raves that's one place where we do all
communica
like come come together without actually
having to be in their presence
so what i had to do was put out content
where the in in in the title
is relative to them so when someone
searching something about a club night
i'm going to pop up someone said
searching something about drugs this
that prison
i'm gonna pop up and that's what
happened so it was primarily over
facebook
and alhamdulillah got really big and
then uh then the youtube channel
followed right after that
so that's really how the new session
project came about it's a project where
you know we're able to reach out to
people that are furthest away from the
dean
and they're going through serious social
problems
but they find that the solution to those
social problems is in talking
in their lives in connection with the
world's didn't follow the messenger so i
saw him
that's really how it came about
i'm the love man let me let me just
say uh my apologies i i didn't say nasty
i said she's i said doubt man so
i just want to correct myself but yeah
they don't know school schools but they
kind of center them all right all right
me bro romney what's on your mind
bro you muted yeah my laptop like glitch
out a little bit
but uh what's on my mind is still this
guy was
giving dawah in the nightclubs uh this
might it must have been like really
early on then masha'allah
yeah we no we didn't actually go into
the nightclub we just had the
when did you start to make the
transition to youtube and when did you
really
start to see you know your channel um
getting more popular and getting more
attraction and reaching more people
it's not my channel imagine what
happened got traction really from day
one
it got it got traction from day one from
there because
um because um
no one was doing this there's very few
projects that were
that were from that were from the from
the muslim community that were reaching
out to the youth
and all of them were doing really well
for example royal tech islam i'm not
sure if you've heard of that channel
uh the brother abubakar islam who runs a
charity in gambia right now he used to
he started off giving doubt to the kids
in the streets and doing interviews with
all these guys that converted from
serious gangs and
drug backgrounds and so his channel it
picked off straight away and there was
there was maybe about two or three at
the time
so mine was unique in that it was
dealing with these social problems that
actually these people
people really don't want to talk about
them so straight away
it popped off like i remember i'd be
getting 50 to 100 000 views per video
and that was my first channel but then
what happened is it got taken down
uh some atheist guy complained some you
know something happened
so i made a video about this atheist
back with richard duke then basically
i got another channel uh and then i had
to build that up again
and that channel got even bigger uh and
same way you know the views was coming
fifty thousand hundred thousand views
per video
but in that channel got taken down as
well
yeah there was you know it was uh back
and forth with some other universe
he kind of gives them advice some issues
about their visions basically
our channels shut down basically uh then
this now is my third youtube channel um
and alhamdulillah you know it's still
popping and everything or whatever
happened
but the issue is that you know when you
run a third youtube channel
uh it's just it's like the same the same
traction from the audiences and there
because this is the third channel number
two uh i feel like you know youtube they
shadow by me a lot because
i've i'm actually i'm actually really
not afraid to say
what it is and say it directly just i'm
saying so from that angle
like alhamdulillah is it's always been
like as in the youth have always been
feeling
uh this daughter i guess you know
there's always going to be that the the
antagonism there's always been people
that are not really feeling it
but it's just you know what it is as
they a real recognized rule so
when you're when you're speaking to
these kids you speak to these youngsters
these boys these girls
they have these problems they actually
want to get out of this mess they don't
enjoy doing what they're doing they know
the heart yearns to have a relationship
with allah
they wish that we could you know what
i'm saying like even the fitrah
the prophet said that allah is placed
something in everyone's heart
even the catholic to know when he is
strained
and that something is wrong for example
the prophet saws
that evil is that which feels
uncomfortable in the chest does that
make sense like when you want to do
something
like a man came to prophet islam and he
asked him what is good what is bad
the prophet saws he said ask your heart
ask your heart what does it mean by that
is that sometimes you know you you know
sometimes we look for
is this halal and uh it's like
but you weren't you're only asking
because you feel uncomfortable about it
and you ask about shisha smoking [ __ ]
like is it the fact that you're asking
is indicating that there's something
uncomfortable about it would you say
bismillah before you smoke
would you would you say bismillah before
you start listening to a trap because
we'll say bismillah before we do things
right
uh generally the rule is do be save the
bismillah before you do things
so you can have the barakah uh of the
name of elizabeth in the actions and the
things that you do
so when we don't say it when we come
certain things because we know
that it's something uncomfortable about
it so everyone has that in them
i know it's all these guys he could be
the most craziest drug dealer to be a
guy who stabbed people up
could be a guy who's in jail for murder
they have this in them
even the non-muslims have it in them
that's why for example when they've done
some studies
to see why is it that when a child lies
for the first time
his heart starts pace fast his palms get
sweaty his voice gets croaky
they said it's because the human being
wasn't programmed to lie but they don't
understand obviously they're going to
try and
identify this in the most naturalistic
way possible because their whole world
view is very naturalistic
um but we understand that
that's that's that mechanism that allah
gave insiders to understand us right and
wrong
so all of these kids all these guys they
have it in them
some of them it's just it's buried under
layers of sin
and darkness because the propaganda told
us that every time someone does a sin
there's a black dot that gets placed on
your heart
but it's so black that the heart covers
filth and then they can't tell the
difference between right and wrong
so what you need to do to be able to
help them and you know
you need to that was your help find that
that feel from the heart clean it
so that they so they so that can be
activated you know i used to
uh give doubt to my muslims on the data
tables sometimes muslims will come up to
me they would just say i don't know why
my heart just brought me like
to you that as in and there's something
that
brought me here that i have to speak to
you i was just walking violence i didn't
want
you know i thought you know let me ask
you what's the purpose of life
i mean is there really a god like these
are things that are all that are
happening internally inside of people
you're not saying
so so that's my thing some people they
try to water the doubt or down
because they want to just please the
crowd she's what i'm saying my thing is
i'd rather be real with you and i know
it's going to be hard for you to accept
it but i know
that even though your desires may be
working against me allah has placed
something inside of you that if i can
help activate that with allah's
permission you're gonna hear what i'm
saying that's why i find that even at
the first time someone sees a video of
mine
or they see something i say they feel a
bit uncomfortable it's a bit too raw
it's a bit too right what's he saying it
sounds a bit mad
but then when you listen and you listen
and then you know i after i
had because we're not pulling it out of
our back pockets you know we're not
making this up it's all allah said in
the speech of allah
it appeals to the heart so the more you
hear the movie the more you're like
oh wow wow this actually makes sense you
see what i'm saying so from the angle
i always found that the youth have been
receptive to the devil the
the problem that i find i don't know if
you don't want to go into this
but the problem i found in the data has
not even really
been the use it's bringing people in the
doubt
that's the problem personally so i don't
necessarily want to go into that because
that can take us into a different
direction but me personally
my biggest animosity or my biggest
obstacle and hurdles
have come from the people that are in
the game
yeah i mean please go into it yeah yeah
yeah i was gonna say it bro
go all in yeah and on the side no on the
side no
i want to let romney go before uh
brother imran you get into it but
but they were gravitated by that beard
man they saw that beer they said oh
i don't know but there's something there
i think it's important you know
especially for us three uh if we're
going to you know be giving dawah in one
way shape or form
uh that we hear about some of the
problems we may encounter some things to
look forward to
um so yeah okay you
so basically and and sometimes guys just
so you know i have a tendency to just
talk
so feel free to just because you know i
know it's not a lecture it's a
discussion
i'm not gonna feel offended if you pull
me up
the floor is yours brother yeah no no
because i
actually want to engage with you guys
with anything but it's just that you
know you know when you're always
teaching
and they put i'm sometimes in a day i'm
giving three lectures now for an hour
each so i just i'm used to it
okay
you know he drew a line in the ground he
drew a line on the ground
and said this is the part of allah
and then after you drew that straight
line he drew many lines that would
deviate from the straight path
and we drew the lines deviating off the
straight path he said
all of these lines are paths that oppose
the path of allah
and upon each one is the devil
he's giving down his calling he's saying
he's giving dawah to devi off the right
path
so then we know that the devils are two
types of the devils that are jinn
and the devils that are humans and
there's humans
that call you to evil and the jinn they
call you to evil so
now we've got human devils and the
prophet said you use the word
they give now they are giving that are
they calling you off that path does that
make sense
because shaytan he you know remember
allah azzawajal said that shaitaan
when allah was going to cost him a
paradise
and he told him to get out he said
then i'm going to come to them from the
front i'm going to come to them from the
back
then i'm going to come from the right
and i'm going to come to them from the
left what does it mean is
that that he's going to come from the
right so i'm going to score it i think
ali
allah he said that this means
that i'm going to come to them in
matters of religion i'm going to confuse
their religion for them i'm going to
make the religion confusing for them
does that make sense
so these are people who are on their
deen have you ever wondered how come
that you come to the dean like i've had
guys
who are involved in crazy gang violence
in the streets and so much groups and
gangs
and that role there's more gangs in the
religion
there's more there's more obviously
you're not killing each other not
selling drugs but
it's more like groups and divisions in
the religion because there's so much
ambiguity because this is one of
shaytan's plans he's
because because at the end of the day he
wants you to not follow allah
so either he's going to make you
blatantly disobey allah or he's going to
make you
think you're following allah but really
you're not that's even more dangerous
when you think that i'm actually doing
something that's correct i'm actually
pleasing allah i'm actually worshiping
on you
do it does that make sense for example a
christian and a christian
who gives charity and you know turns the
other cheek and
you know love thy neighbor and you know
all these these are good things
but he's doing it for jesus he's not
doing it for a lot so all that good he's
doing is actually going down the drain
so at the end of the day he's far away
from allah and so is the guy on the
streets far away from allah
but you know this guy is more dangerous
you know what a christian because he
thinks
that allah is actually happy with him he
thinks that this is what god wants
at least the guy is selling drugs
fornicating sleep around he knows in his
heart this is wrong one day i'm going to
victoria
and this is what you call bidder you
know in this in
in amongst the muslims there's this
concept of the prophet
he said this is the this he said if you
live anyone from amongst you who lives
you're going to see a lot of differences
a lot of disputation
the solution is to follow me and my
companions the prophet said
and then he told us to stay away from
the problem we should be bid our
innovation which is to make things up
that we
introduce new things in a religion so
there are
73 sects and 72 of them do bidder they
they are on something else does that
make sense
some of the video reaches kufa like some
of the groups of the shia for example
they
they they worship their imams they
actually worship them does that make
sense some of the groups of the sufis
they worship the graves of their saints
so the buddha can reach this belief and
some of them it doesn't reach this
belief but
it's what they could the point is that
there's 72 of them and there's only one
path that is guiding there's only one
path that says we're gonna do what the
prophet said
and what allah said and how do we
understand what allah and the prophet
want the companions because the prophet
told us that the group that will be
saved is the ones who follow me
and they follow my companions
what's happening when the companies are
who is that one safe sect this is the
ones who follow me
i'm a companion so this is something
that you brothers need to always look
out for that whenever you hear someone
talking
in a situation of religion where there
is a dispute
where there is differences of opinion
the question that needs to always pop
into your mind
is that what do the companions say about
this
because at the end of the day every
group claims to follow allah and the
prophet
every group claims but they all have
different interpretations
how do you know what the correct
interpretation is the companions because
they were there
at the time the revelation came down
they were there and the prophet taught
them the meanings in fact when the
prophet when the companions didn't
understand something in the quran
they would ask about islam and either he
would explain or allah would send down a
verse
answering their question for them so so
you have to follow
the prophet islam and his companions
because you can't
you can't know what the prophet is
telling you without the companions the
same way
if i need to know a hadith of the
prophet i have to have the companion who
narrated it
that's why you hear this hadiva's
narrative this new hadith is narrated by
this narrative because if the companion
is not there the hadith was weak we call
that a chain that's disconnected
because that chain is disconnected
because the companions missing so the
same way i need the companion for the
wording of the hadith i need to complain
for the interpretation as well
so my point is that when you're given
that one and you're trying to give that
pure islam
the authentic islam the original islam
you've got about 72 different groups
that you're against
you see so now when i'm out here
trying to give that out to these kids
and i'm trying to bring them at the same
time to the
authentic islam but when i bring them to
the authentic islam they said
that pull them towards their direction
do you see that's why i find that the
biggest problem comes from these guys
because
getting the kids into the masjid is not
hard but it's when they're in the
machine which group do they end up going
to join
and some of them end up doing a group
that takes them to isis and then they
blow themselves up after
enough and i've had kids that received
my dawah
and ended up on the front page of
newspapers
as as as as as uh you know
on the wantedness of the of the british
government
in iraq and then the next day you hear
already got bombed last night
good kids but look where they ended up
we
kids that were good and now they end up
grave worshiping
which is i mean that's worse than
christians
because at least christians they do [ __ ]
by the people of the book which is not
bad
they're still not muslims but you know
remember not all the disbelievers
are of the same level like the one
that's why you know we're allowed to eat
their meat
you know like the christians for example
but but i'm saying now for you to go
become a grave version you're not even a
person in the book it's a different
religion now
you know what i'm saying so so that's
where we we have this confusion amongst
the muslim and then there's liberal
muslims
then there's extremist muslims uh
extremely liberal extremely overboard
there's the ignorant muslims
so that's what we find that where the
problem is and i'll give you like and
i'll show you practically and then i'll
stop talking because i think i'm
a bit long in this but but uh to show
you practically how it directly actually
impacts
our dawah this this concept so there's a
group called the asha
there's a group called and they're a
very
very big group amongst the muslim
community does that make sense and they
don't believe
they don't affirm allah's names and
attributes
in the way that for
he becomes happy when a slave makes toba
they're like what do you mean happy
no as in they reinterpret this to mean
other things
they say they say if you say allah loves
and allah
becomes happy and allah laughs you're
comparing allah to the human beings
we say no we're not they say allah said
there's nothing like him we say we know
there's nothing like him but allah told
us
he's the one or his messenger is the one
who told us that he becomes happy when
his slave makes over or that he laughs
or that he loves or that he
you know he has this characteristic of
mercy or that he has these
characteristics
so allah subhanahu wa to allah himself
for his messenger told us
but what we know is that the way allah
loves is different to how we love
and the way he loves different how we
laugh the same way allah told us he has
he has changed but now i know that right
hand but my hand is not like a lot hand
and why is it so hard for you to
understand that
the clock the clock on the wall has a
hand you use the same word because the
hand points a hand is used for pointing
hand is used for many things hand points
had grabs hand is something that you do
things with
so the reason why they call the the hand
of a clock
a hand is because it points so by the
other hand the clock has a hand because
we share a function which is pointing
but you and i both know that my hand in
the clock's hand is not the same
they are two different hands so when
allah tells me as a hand why is it so
hard
to understand his hand is nothing like
our hand you know what i'm saying so
this is just a background so you
understand this this point that i'm
coming to you
so now i'm in a mystery and there's an
imam giving and he's saying that you
know we need to stop talking about these
issues of allah's names and his
attributes
because we've got kids killing each
other on the streets so we need to
address these issues
these classical discussions have not
affected our day and age
they have no effect in our day and age
so i said to him hold up
after the salah i went to him in a nice
way and i said [ __ ] i work for the kids
in the streets and i teach them these
issues of arcada
and i find first hand that actually
benefits them so he looks at me and he
says let me be rude
he goes when has a ash admin who denies
allah's names attributes when have they
ever got in the way of your doubt
i said wow let me explain to you i said
one of allah's names
is the honor
and the possessor of pride like which we
call arrogance for us
is bad for us because how can we think
we're great
arrogance is to to not to to be to
to say and to be better than everyone
else but we're not better than everyone
else we're all the same
but you're trying allah because he
actually is better than everyone else
does that make sense so we have verses
in a hadith
to tell us we can't be arrogant because
only allah has the right
to show his greatness over everyone else
does that make sense so this is
something unique for allah
now this group that they don't accept
for allah these names like they say no i
mean something else it means this it
means that it means this it means that
so i'm like if you work with the kids on
the streets you know one of the biggest
reasons why they're kidding each other
it's because of arrogance it's because
of respect so one of the biggest things
that i'm going to do when i see a kid on
the street i'm going to tell him how
great a lie is i'm telling you how
powerful allah is
i'm going to think about the greatness
of allah and how you know all of these
things
so he so he humbles himself but now if
the same guy goes
he's going to tell him that this is
metaphorical it doesn't really apply
because
you know what i'm saying so so these how
are you going to
the biggest problem or one of the
biggest problems that the kids on the
street
experience is arrogance that's why
they're killing each other
you know unfortunately said this two
years people end up in hell money
as a misappropriation of money or
acquiring the money from bad means
number two women are you know doing
doing mad haram things to get women and
number three
arrogance right status you know what i'm
saying so this is one of the primary
reasons people end up in hell but you
but but
if i if if you tell me stop teaching
people and stop
correcting these corrupted beliefs i
mean these guys are gonna listen
and they're going to say oh well so i
could be arrogant so i am greater than
everyone else on the block
i do run the block no one can test me do
something i'm saying so
there's many examples of that so i my
biggest issue and biggest opposition
comes from
the muslim community that claim to be
given doubt which you're not saying
so then i guess uh it goes without
saying that
experience will be the biggest indicator
as to if someone's
legit you know saying the right dollar
or not
because um if if someone doesn't have
the experience and they're just speaking
theoretically they're speaking in in a
way where they're perceiving ah well
this
will reach the best this will help the
best but it's like unless you've had
that experience you won't know a hundred
percent
um but with that being said i have a
question bro
so you said that a few of the brothers
that you were
giving dollar to ended up on the
newspaper
basically on the one in this like how
does that even happen like what happens
to people
that they end up going down that route
and like what
what's so attractive about that to them
fantastic so just just just just just
before i go into that so
uh experience definitely helps but
what's more important that experience is
knowledge
for example if a person is studying the
correct creed the character
that they study the deen then for
example they don't make these mistakes
like for
you know they say a wise man uh learns
from the mistakes of others
a wise man learns from the mistakes of
others and a fool never learns
so so instead of you know like
experience
it necessitates i have to make the
mistakes myself
and then eventually i'll get to the
right answer but how many mistakes i'm
making process i could just avoid all of
those mistakes
by just going and saying what do you
online is messenger and the scholars
before me
what did they say and then i can avoid
all of that so that that i find is very
helpful but
yeah so how it happens is it happens
exactly how i just just
just just mentioned it to you so there
was this kid uh
may allah have mercy on me you know he
used to attend more programs i used to
teach some stuff online
um but i used to never really teach
people like the reading the deen
i was just doing a course on how to give
that out to atheists
so he was attending that course and he
was like he was loving
you know he had his phone number and he
was on whatsapp would talk communicate
he even invited me to his message in his
local community and
you know he he really benefited from my
doubt he grew and he developed
now at this time the whole isis
situation was going on
and uh and uh you know a lot of people
are asking me what
what is your view what do you think
what's your perception
and uh i always kept quiet on the issue
because i always said to myself
it's not my place it's not my place
and then this kid ended up getting cured
because i remain silent
he ended up going there allah knows how
he might have killed
and not getting killed himself do you
see so now i said to myself how many
kids are they that watch my stuff
that ended up going because i don't know
what it was like in the states
but london got hit hard as in where i'm
from in the uk
some of the best kids some of the best
of the best youngsters who came to the d
and started practicing the dean
they ended up joining in
or they're in jail so we actually lost a
great practice in community
he lost a great practicing community
because of that whole fitness
and i decided to remain silent so for me
it's like you know when you give down
you have a responsibility you have a
responsibility to
address issues and for our own personal
you know am i gonna get cancelled uh uh
shut down from
attending uh from being able to come
into a particular country or
attend a particular university to give
my lectures like these are things that
hit the duat
like for example when it's what
palestine thing was going on
a lot of people were attacking certain
doubt personalities for remaining silent
now i don't think that every person has
to speak about every issue
you may genuinely not have something to
say may not think that your contribution
is beneficial
but you know there are people that are
known to always comment on everything
so when you always when you're always
known to comment on things
and then this is like the kind of thing
which is right up your alley and you
remain silent
people will wonder why like why have you
remained silent and then it kind of
became
clear or they kind of worried about them
whether they're going to be able to get
into certain countries because
because you know when you speak against
the zionists the countries where you go
give darwin are very
scientist friendly so it's like the
duration always thinking about their own
personal
you know uh not ordered by the way
there's real ones i'm talking about the
guys that we need to kind of clean
the whole you know system from yeah
there's there are that are real
you know what i'm saying but there are
those that unfortunately they make the
mainstream the reason they make the
mainstream is because they try to please
everyone
so i was there like me i was also my
thing was like i don't
i don't you know i don't want to get
into this issue it's not really my
thing but then look out look how look
how hypocritical that is
because the whole reason i started my
channel was to help the muslim youth
that which was affecting them so when
drugs and alcohol is affecting them i
have a problem
when they are being pulled
into a terrorist organization i want to
remain quiet
because i'm scared of the backlash
because i'm scared it's not really my
thing
so that really woke me up and then i
started to address it from that day
onward i realized to myself i said to
myself
um i need to touch these issues and the
first
controversial islamic issue remember
social issues are not controversial
to provide islamic solutions for drugs
alcohol you know this that
family problems everyone's happy
everyone agrees you know even shia are
going to agree with me
even even even the isis guys are going
to agree they say you do a good job bro
everyone's going to agree but when
there's controversial islamic issue
for example issues of you know rebellion
against the rulers fighting jihad
and by the way we're not saying that you
know jihad ain't real
i mean as we it is but what they was
doing was not jihad that's our
muslims it's not jihad does that make
sense killing muslims
are muslims it's not jihad so when i
told them these issues for example
muslims that grave worship that worship
other gods besides allah for some of the
muslims that celebrate the birth
so for me like it's sad that a muslim
would go and end up joining isis because
i remain silent but what's scarier
is a muslim ends up committing [ __ ]
because i remain silent
that's even more scary because i mean
joining
us which is evil we're not trying to
believe in it
but what's the greatest evil the
worshipping of god besides allah so
that's that that's that's how it happens
that there's people putting
all of our kids in different directions
and you know
and that's why you know what happens to
a lot of kids actually uh some kids
they join the dean they come to the team
and then they get confused and then they
find a group that misleads them whatever
that group may be
but other muslims in fact i mean
maybe even a lot of them they come to
the dean they see the fight in
and then they leave they're like you
know what this is wrong
this is this this is that being on the
streets and then they go back so that's
why it's just the the
really i think where the the fight is
and the biggest problem is
it's in the muslim community i'll give
another example you see this palestine
issue
it's not parasite i'm sure you saw all
the protests and people that were
protesting and so on and so forth
okay and how many of these people that
gave that or what the folks
how many shares at the protest will
encourage people
to protest does that make sense now
whether you believe protest permissible
or not i don't want to talk about that
but i i'm obviously the protesters are
not permissible
but that's a different discussion right
at the very least you know
that the protest if you believe that
it's permissible and you're going to
tell people to come to the protest
at the end of the day you know and i
know that allah doesn't give victory
to the muslims
it's the corruption spread in the land
of the sea because of the same that we
did with our hands
another
muslims like they're gathering around a
plate of fruit
they're about to feast on us and the
companion said is this because we will
be
uh uh uh lower number the prophetism
said no
rather you be bigger number but the
issue is that you would
love would love you would love uh
the life and you hate death meaning you
follow your desires you just want to
live you just want to sin you just want
to
you you don't have hope for that you
don't live for that for the day
judgment you don't you you just live for
the day does that make sense and there's
many narrations that the
nomination the prophet isaiah said that
humiliate this ummah when we sin
and he mentions some of the sins that we
do and allah will not uplift the human
nation till we come back to our deen
so i'm saying now let's just have
authentically assumed for
argument's sake protesting is
permissible and i don't believe this but
let's just say
that you believe that okay now you've
got all these kids and these people that
are coming to the protest
but you know based on textual evidences
whether protesters miss or not but you
know that allah doesn't
help the muslims until we come back to
worship in allah
and to believe of us we have to repent
from our sins
and we have to correct our soul and then
allah will fix our state of affairs
because
i wanted to change the state of the
people
until they change themselves so you have
to teach them listen to change
themselves
so now you've got all these muslims that
are coming to the protests
but they're playing music and they're
freaks
and the girls are wearing hijab and if
they are wearing hijab
it's they've got tight kites from and
there's music and there's vandalism and
there's this and it's that
now my question is when when at the
battle of bedok
when allah gave victory to the compa the
companions
[Music]
that are bigger than them in number they
had better artillery than them they had
more cavalry than them
they were better equipped in every shape
form but allah gave them victory
was why did i like giving that victory
because the prophet spent the whole
night begging allah
he's begging allah his hands behind the
skies a lot you know he was still he was
savage
it was absence from sin in fact which is
the sword where allah talks about
the preparing the believers for victory
allah describes the beliefs allah
scared because when someone says
and then they lie like when you say
allah the world should stop
wait you just said the name of the lord
what are you saying
that's the characteristic of the people
and if the verse of allah recite
it they
people now rely upon the politicians
more they rely upon allah they call out
to their mps and their politicians more
than
protesting is you calling out to your
governments are you putting the effort
informed out to allah
then allah said they pray and then they
give this a cat do we pray do we know
how to pray do we give this a cat do we
know how to give zakat
these are the so interesting because
certainly
and
this is exactly the story of palestine
you know being overcome by the
oppressors and
numbers you know their odds are stacked
against them these are the ones that
allah is telling you he's going to give
rich
to them and the story is about how to
get rich but it starts by saying
when allah's name is mentioned the heart
becomes fearful
when you hear the quran your iman
increases you rely on allah you pray and
you give the cat
so my point is that when you look at our
audience that come into the protest
i mean what what is that crowd what is
that audience
is our audience that is worshiping allah
i mean they're clearly sinning publicly
remember there's a guy who sins but he
seems in private
he has he he's in a better place than
the one who seems to think in public so
you've got all these girls coming out
with
hijab and makeup and music and guys and
there was actually
guys on tiptoe that was saying yo come
to the protest there's going to be some
girls there so my point is that as a guy
as a dad as a sheikh as a member of the
community
you must be calling the people to
correctness you must be saying if you're
going to come to the protests
which you shouldn't in the perspective
but if you're gonna come you must tell
them correct these issues
but they won't correct these issues you
know why because their concern is not
reading the people
their concern seems to be just saying
what's going to make them popular
because the i mean the whole palestine
thing you were anyone who was talking
about was getting loads of views
never getting loads of comments i mean
they did some people were not by a
hundred thousand followers
hundred thousand subscribers in just
about two weeks because it's the thing
that everyone's talking about
but the moment you start telling people
what really they need they may not want
to hear it so then your numbers will
draw does that make sense so i thought
it was criminal
that the muslims are suffering through a
pain because of it they are suffering
and they are they are defeated
and you have the knowledge to tell them
how correct that
but you don't for your own personal
whether it be your creed that is
corrupted whether it be your own
personal benefit
but it's it's it's just disastrous
because when we don't want to be real
with the community
we're actually it's imagine imagine you
come to the hospital
and you've got a big wound in your head
and headache but the doctor said i'm
gonna treat
headache and then i'm gonna and the
bullet wouldn't you know
he just kind of maybe doesn't even
attend that he'll get sentenced to y'all
for malpractice
and the guy came to you with a bullet
wound and you gave him aspirin for his
headache
what are you doing so people come to you
would be that i would [ __ ] with all
these problems
and you told them ah we need to talk
about good manners
you know what i'm saying you're cheating
the people that's that's one of the
reasons why one of the first people
will be punished on the day of judgement
as the prophet isam said
even before i had worshipped as a person
who came to be a person knowledge that
was teaching people but he actually
didn't do it for the sake of allah
he didn't do it for allah he did it why
so people could say oh he's
knowledgeable he get the followers you
get the
money from just whatever happened so yes
it's a messed up situation
so with that being said though
because i'm just trying to get in the in
the minds of like these people who
end up going that route like what
actually
and i know this would probably be
something vague this is just
theoretical because we we're not in them
you know we aren't them we don't have
their mindset in that
and that predicament but these people
that
are going into the whole isis movement
like what is
drawing them to it like why are they why
are they even doing it because like
if you look at muslims who aren't doing
that um
yeah you ask them oh why aren't you
doing that and they'll be like they
could clearly tell you like oh well it's
just
extreme so then what what's the
difference here like what
was the disconnect was it what's
happening in these people's minds
um uh they there's many ways to answer
it but the crux of the matter comes down
to this
yeah the same reason why people the
the the actually believe that what opens
the door for people to go to join isis
is actually the liberal who sneezes and
i'll tell you why
i'll tell you why and what
and and isis guy will come to you know
bring you a verse
where i lost hannah said you know uh
do what allah tells me to do so make
sense now
now now now what's he doing
he's doing what i remember i said at the
beginning he's not going to the
interpretation of the companions
because the the text of the universe the
time in place
because in fact you know this isis
the classically this group is called and
they've existed at the time they
complained they
would bring these verses to the
companions themselves and they used to
clarify this is not what it means
does that make sense so these guys now
what they're doing is that they're
bringing the vest they interpreting
themselves does that make sense so now
the muslims that don't want to follow
the companions that don't want to follow
the sahaba they don't want to follow the
stellar
they criticize the isis guys they say
you
are taking the verse out of context
so we look back at them and the isis
guys look back at them and they say
don't you do the same thing we learned
this from you
we love we actually don't you know
people believe that a lot of the isis
supporters came out of the selfie
movement
that's incorrect but when i said who
mean wrong but that
said if he said if he means the ones who
follow the companions basically that's
what it means it just it just
it's just a way to describe that i take
my understanding from prophet's
companions that's all
right so but it's actually not true they
actually came out of the liberal
movement a lot of them
they came the political
because the whole concept because if if
you if you follow
if you follow the seller then every time
you come to a verse
someone's going to say to you wait wait
what did the prophet say about it what
did a bucket say about
what did about the verse and then
that's it you've solved your problem
because you're picking up from a place
where the guy understands
that there is a god to measure the
meaning of the verse
these guys went back wild because
they were not nurtured out of a out of
an understanding of the deed whereas
that we can interpret the quran however
we can interpret it without the need of
the settlement
without the need of the prophet's
companions so when i
look at these you know guys that are
very you know these political muslims
that are very anti-isis that are very
liberal
bro you did this what you you created
isis or you know
not that you created isis but you
created a
environment that would be a catalyst for
the ideology to grow
does that make sense because the same
way they're taking versus out of context
you're taking that they say they're
important in the verses from themselves
don't tempt the message from yourselves
the only way to solve this problem
is to come and get the prophet's
companions interpretations and the
prophet's interpretations of the verses
but that's what happens you see so
there's
many other issues which is for example
you know a lack of knowledge
lack of understanding being coerced this
that
confused coming from our background of
being anti-establishment anyway
anti-government anti-police and then you
start practicing and you're going to be
you may have that natural inclination to
join this academy but really at the end
of the day
what they do is that they use their
religion to justify whatever it is that
they do right
so the problem comes back down to what
is your understanding of the religion
so these guys are guilty of this of the
same thing
of the same thing that's why you know
you know for some things you guys say
you have to must unite with all the
different groups and all the different
sects
so why don't you want to unite with isis
why don't you
not because they did what makes them
different bro they do what you do
it's just that they interpret the verse
and end up killing someone
you interpret the verse and ended up
telling someone that you know uh
mortgage is halal is halal and you know
you can free mix and you interpret the
verse to say that you know bidah is
allowed and
you know [ __ ] is allowed that's actually
what
actually
i got a question though it's a little
different i'm a restructure a lot of
people that are
that are watching and myself included i
came to you through your videos on
you know addictions and you know
substances quitting you know
porn and all that so for any any
brothers right now let's say they're
suffering with something right
they're suffering with either porn or
xena or
alcohol or weed what would you have to
say what what would be like your
golden takeaways
the first and foremost thing to
understand
when it comes to these vices we will not
be able to
we need allah's aid to get out of it
right
we need allah to get out of here there's
these steps there's many stages
anything we can say there's practical
solutions there's
you know this that and the religion
gives you practical solutions lowering
your
gaze not being around the kind of
companions that would
reinforce that kind of you know uh vice
and that kind of addiction
you know not like these are all
practical things that the religion comes
but there's a foundational limited
religion comes with that means
which gives the need to ask and beg
allah and i'll give an example
the thing of addictions and what not
like one of the primary addictions that
men suffer from
is the addiction of women whether that
be manifested be manifested
in fornication or whatever happened
right so in the story of use of ali
for example where the woman wanted to
sleep with him by the tata that she said
yusuf sleep with me you know i'm saying
imagine a beautiful woman comes up to
you
locked the door barricaded it shut uh
and not just one door many doors it's
just her and him
she's a beautiful mission a woman of
status now
relationship like no one's gonna know no
one's gonna see he's a stranger in the
land it's not like
rumors can spread about him in the
community he's in egypt he's actually
from a different land in virginia but
he's in egypt now
this whole situation is set up to make
it easy for him to fornicate
but he realized that there are so many
things that are leading me to do the
evil
and i'm done for if allah doesn't help
me so immediately
what does he do because we know he runs
to the door
we know he runs to the door and then the
door flings open
but why did he run to the door before
he did something greater he said
he said allah asked refugees from this
the first thing he did was that he asked
for allah's help
point one underline that that's the
first thing he did
then in the next verse you learn that
allah
this is so profound because we haven't
even got into him running away the door
opening
the pr we haven't got the practical
stuff yet all we know right now
is that he called that allah his
passport a lot i
mean help there is a woman in front of
me she's asking me i'm a man
today i need you my lord save me from
this evil save me from this vice
save me from his addiction save me from
this
oh allah tells him
which means that allah saved him because
he was the person that was sincere he
was worshiping a lot alone
that shows you that what's going to save
you from these problems
is that relationship with allah right of
i spend my time worshiping allah i spend
my time praying
i spend my time connecting with allah i
don't worship god besides him
i purify my intentions i fight to make
sure that you know i don't place anyone
equal to allah i don't love anyone more
than a
lot of hopes but my fears
from anyone else of the faith that i was
just pleasing a lot of punishment like
my life is focused and orientated around
allah so the first thing is that we know
that
used to from very very orientated
regards to
worshipping allah and calling out to
allah and relying upon allah and allah
actually told us that is why he saved
him okay that's round one with yusuf
right round two
round two oh so sorry then after that he
runs through the door
uh sorry give me one second guys yeah uh
charger in because my batch is not for
that uh so then he wants to do a fast
run through the door a miracle happens
the door opens remember
but alhamdulillah allah opened the door
and he made it so that her husband
walked through the door
that's round one round two round two
is that the woman she prepared peace
because
the narrow rumors are spreading in the
scene that she wanted to sleep with her
sleep
and that's kind of like what you're like
a honorable woman you're like
royalty and you wanted to slain you know
so she wanted to show all the women in
the city
let me show you why i love this sleigh
let me show you how handsome
because we know how handsome music was
today
you know prepare the banquet she gave
all of the food she gave them knives
they were cutting the knives
so that you know everyone's like helping
with the you know they're cutting the
the vegetables or whatever have you
so as they cutting it she told yusuf
walk in and as he walks
in when they saw him
he would admire him
in
imagine looking at someone so handsome
that you slice through your fingers and
you don't even feel it
imagine you just chopping chopping
chopping chopping chopping what chopped
your finger
and you don't even realize because
you're in such all about how handsome
this man is
so now they all wanted to smoke
now it's not just one woman it's many
women
and what indicates that is that in the
verse allah
[Music]
i'm going to become from the ignorant
ones so he didn't say save him from her
plot but he's the plural because now
it's not just one woman after him
there's many women after him does that
make sense
so so he made dua again that's what i
want to come to
again he said he said
i am going to fall into what they're
calling me to and i'll become from the
ignorance
again against allah again he's showing
allah i need you so so so
in the story of yusuf you know we miss
we hear about the door open he ran to
the door he chose
jail he chose prison but we don't
realize that before each of those things
he called out to allah
and that's why it's so important that we
understand if there's any vice
any addiction whether it be drugs
whether it be masturbation whether it be
pornography whether it be women
whether it be gambling whatever it may
be your first stage you must beg a lot
does that make sense because we can take
all the practical steps that we want for
days by the end of the day
we need a lot to aid us to give us the
strength and there's something that
muslims forget
we need allah so much that you know have
we all ever wondered why is it that
in in al-fatiha when we pray our salah
we say i cannot believe
why did allah please worship and hope
right next to each other because we
can't worship allah in the first place
without his help in the first place does
that make sense
that's why at the end of every prayer
the prophet told us to make a dua allah
and to be grateful to you and to worship
you in a good way we need allah's aid
to worship we need allah's aid to
remember we need allah to stay away from
the sins
so i feel like you're not in the past
i've mentioned many things and also with
daniel when i did the podcast first you
know we talked about practical steps
how to overcome pornography and whatnot
you know a lot of that stuff is there
fasting this that
a lot of things are there but one thing
which is not there
is that begging allah that turning to
allah does that make sense
and also thinking good of allah to know
that every time you turn to allah
and even if you slip up again because
allah understands that addictions
like allah knows you right and he knows
that he's not you're not going to
overcome the addiction overnight like
it's a process so you may relapse but to
know that with allah you have a safe
space
that every time you slip up and you come
back to allah he's still going to be
there for you and an analogy i like to
give
is you know like for example imagine
there's a mom and there's
and she has a child and she's teaching
her child to walk
so the mom what she does is when she
sees a child can stand and take a few
steps
the mom places the child at the other
end of the room and she stands at the
other end of the room
and the child wants to come to the one
because he loves the mom
so so the child gets up and it takes a
step
it takes a step with people what does
the child do it falls it relapses
does that make sense but when the child
relapses
the mom waits for the child to get back
up again and as the child makes the
effort to fight
against the odds to get up the mom
loves the child that much more because
the child is trying to get closer to him
the mom sees
and to eventually the child relapses
again he pulls
no problem as long as the child gets up
again
that love is still there does that make
sense until eventually mom just picks up
the childhood
and just and just holds the child so
analogy and of course the example of
allah is greater i'm not trying to
compare allah to the mum or anything
like that
but you know allah sees a slave make
efforts towards him
but slave might have a relapse okay
don't feel
shy of as i said i said feel shy have
embarrassment have guilt
but not to the point where you feel like
you can't come to allah that don't come
back to him
and he loves you that much more that he
sees you trying
you're trying with the pornography
you're trying with the alcohol you're
trying with the drugs
every time you're coming back and then
you know
i'm not saying this it's acceptable to
just relapse no but i'm saying if it
naturally happens despite your efforts
despite your efforts
know that allah has shut down allah is
not turning away
that makes sense as long as you're
trying you keep begging you keep asking
you know what you might have nothing
who's knocking at allah's door well
that's not going to reject you
allah is not going to leave you outside
no the the point of the matter is you
keep trying and try and find until
eventually
allah will bring you in so i feel like
this this this number one coming to
allah and then having that at you to
know that coming to allah is a safe
space
regardless of whatever sin you're
struggling with whatever vice or
addiction
i think these three things they are uh
rv their essence of overcoming
addictions
i really appreciate the answer because i
feel like a lot of people you know
including ourselves
um either we forget to mention
ask for allah's help or we just say ask
for allah that's it
but we don't i feel like you know
especially myself we don't understand
the severity and the gravity
of asking for allah's help and how
important it is and the fact that you
took
all that time to answer that maybe
doesn't even do it justice to the
gravity of how important it is but
alhamdulillah
i'm glad that you you took that approach
first and foremost and especially at
this point in that approach alone
because
subhan allah would like as you said with
allah you're crying bro
bro man honestly
you know it's so deep i thought i
actually realized something new i
realized something that we as in i'm
actually planning to do
uh we have this hot uh show on my
youtube channel for childhood mumbai
i'm just planning to record this um i
think tuesday
and i was just speaking to the brothers
the topic is that we have misunderstood
allah
that we've actually misunderstood allah
like you know you know what i'm saying
that we as a community
as a people asleep you misunderstood our
lord
like it's true like you know there's two
extremes the people who
who like always bang on about the mercy
of allah without
without without the fear and there's all
that focus from the fear without the
mercy
and you need both of them but both of
those two things
there's a third thing as well which is
in the middle which is love
i love allah because imam even fame said
that you know to get to allah
you need to be like a bird and a bird in
order to fly has two wings and it has a
head
one wing is hope the other wing is fear
hope and fear balance keep your balance
if you only have one wing you're gonna
fall right if you have too much hope
you're gonna sin and think you're gonna
be like the christian we can do whatever
we want jesus died for our sins
does that make sense or if you're or or
or
if there's too much faith you're gonna
you you're gonna be like the jews
too much faith does that make sense and
they became extreme on some issues
so you need to have the balance of hope
for fear and
the head because again these are not
enough to make the thigh right
you have a breath in the head so the
head of the bird is love we don't know
about allah enough to love him to know
him to know who he is like you know
which is you know where the prayer is
said allah said
that i am how my slave thinks of me
if he thinks good of me then good and
he's inspired me
then this bathroom
explain this in such a profound way he
said like so you know every time you say
allah you know every time you say allah
i ask you forgive me i seek your
forgiveness
he said at that time the slaves should
have had good assumption of allah
because allah said i am as my slave
thinks of me
so then at the time of asking allah to
forgive me
i need to think of allah as one who
right now is going to forgive my
every sin big and small public and
private
no no matter you know how many of them
they are i need to think right now at
this minute
and believe that allah is going to
literally
forgive every one time i say
sincerity with such certainty and such
good assumption of allah that allah
you're gonna literally wipe my sleep
clean after this one word i'm gonna say
but we don't you know why we're not ah
he's not really gonna forgive that
we don't really think good of allah and
that's because we don't know him
that is that there's a verse
said he's forgiving and he's loving why
did allah place these two names
because of allah's names why did he
place these two names together he's not
supposed he doesn't do it for no reason
it's not just he just chose and put
words together it means to give up
he puts these names together for a
reason so allah mentioned he's forgiven
and loving and the reason why the
scholars say he did it the secret in
that is
because when allah
forgives you you may think okay allah
you forgive me but you don't love me
because human beings when we when we
violate human beings when we oppress
humans
when we seek their forgiveness they may
forgive us but things may never go back
to how they were
they may not love you anymore right it
may be like okay look it's cool i
forgive you
we have to be civil now we're not really
like that anymore so allah wanted to
show the slave
that despite the murder despite the
fornication the sparkling disbelief
despite the idol worship despite all
that
you did it 10 years 20 years 40 years 50
years you
seek my forgiveness and i forgive you
just so you know i'm loving his whole
meaning i love you again as well
as it never it's as if it never happened
i love you now
do you know what i'm saying
you know what i'm saying then of course
you don't want to you know but then the
verses of fear are there as well just so
you know you you don't take advantage of
allah's love and his medicine
you know at the same time you can't play
a lot you know
and i'm saying but that's not we we
listen we don't know who allah is we
misunderstood allah i really feel like
this is the problem of our community our
life and i wish that i could speak about
allah more than politics
and i wish that we'd speak about allah
and his greatness more than all of these
things
you know i'm saying but imagine right
now we're doing this podcast i know that
there's
going to be some guy who follows a
different sect that's going to cut up
some of these
things that i've said about describing
allian's characteristics
and he's going to start making a video
saying look at him describing allah with
his characteristics
and it's like now after i do this
podcast from you
i'm getting ready for the response to
the confusion that people are gonna
throw it's like well why are you trying
to confuse people about a lot just leave
us alone
but you're gonna see that the problem
comes from
from there you know what i'm saying but
if people just let us just talk about
the game talk about allah talk about
this it's what people need
all right brother so it is
about that time i have one last question
to wrap this all
up because you what you said speaks
magnitude because a lot of people they
might be upset about this
but it's like as a reverb i'm seeing
this very clearly that
we are taught to learn about
the deen we were taught to learn about
the word of allah the hadees and all
this stuff
it's all beautiful but we're not really
taught
how to know allah
so like in in your words how would
someone start to
go about doing this to get closer to
their creator and actually
learn about allah
that's what i'm saying you know it comes
down to seeking knowledge i mean look we
study
science in school science the study of
the natural world
and its processes right and because we
live in the natural world
uh you know the governments and
education systems saw it to be so
important that we're learning
about it from first grade you know we
learn about the solar system and
this and that and the water cycle we
learn about the world in which we exist
because it's important to us now
if we if we learn about things that are
important to us
then obviously that which that which is
more important takes more priority to
learn to go for a system
of education a process of education to
vote for a curriculum to learn to study
um and the creator of the head of the
world is obviously
more important than the world studying
the creator of the world is more
important than studying
the world that he created does that make
sense and
so the same way if i'm going to take out
time to go for a process
of formal education to learn about the
sun the moon the stars the planets
chemistry biology
why am i not going to take out the time
to go through a curriculum to study
to study allah and his message of islam
and
scholars for the last 1400 years have
been have
lined out curriculums for this there's
books that are to be studied for example
the first thing
that we need to study is
so even before we study allah's names
and everything we need to study allah's
greatest right which is to worship alone
that's what makes it different to
everyone else
then the next thing is the things that
he does names
actually characteristics you see there
are books for this
one
there's things like that i have a series
that i started on my channel
but then because i called it i stopped
it because of the massaging being locked
down
it's about the names of allah i always
send people to watch that series you
know if they want to
start getting to know allah like we go
through allah's names you know what i'm
saying
so go through that i have another series
called a study of the shahadah
which is uh you know a study of law
studies
study of how to worship like what it
means to wash allah alone
and you know and the conditions of life
for example love
people don't know that one of the
conditions of that is love they don't
know the condition of life
certainty they're from the condition
that you know the submission knowledge
so
so those two maybe i can send you the
link and you guys can if you feel
comfortable you can put it in the
description
below but but even that is an
introduction people need to pursue a
process of formal education
we have that's why i actually set up an
institute called knowledge college
but we actually teach people this stuff
they sign up
it's a five-year program but we tell
them look even if you can't commit to
five years just commit to the first year
it's just four hours a week four hours a
week for 38 weeks and then just commit
to at least the first year
because in the first year we give you
the absolute necessary things that you
need to learn about your religion you
know what i'm saying
so um that's why like my doubt is so
it's so
like you know i'm not just going for the
kids in the streets i don't know when i
take them off the streets with the push
of elizabeth
and this takes them off and i'm using
things i now need to have an institute
to educate them so it's kind of like if
there's a whole process
and that's why we even set up like you
know all these other projects because
you know in the community of so many
different buyers and now you've got
marriage too so we set up sunday match
because
which is a matchmaking service because
now you're studying a deal and you come
off the streets you want to get married
but you're struggling so
it's it's so there's so much to do that
makes sense you have to find which part
of the journey that you're on
and if you have that journey you gotta
start studying my deen now not a choice
but yeah
i'm saying forget knowledge this is not
me trying to promote anything that would
be able to do that
the point that i'm trying to get across
is that you need to take a process of
education
of islamic studies even if it's
part-time it's basic
because otherwise you're not going to
get it
you're not going to get it you know what
i'm saying
man man
that's listen
i think at some point we're gonna have
to have a part two
of course bro there was so much there
was so much that i wanted to talk about
but
man i feel like we could go on all day
yeah whenever you guys ready man i i i i
i i really like you guys man i like it i
like you too bro
we like it i really like the vibe i
actually wanted to speak to uh fired man
about some health and fitness tips
i was actually thinking bro i was
actually thinking you know where to find
me
bro yeah i might need to i might need to
reason we need to get in shape bro bro
whenever we come to the uk we know we
know we got to link up
or 100 december 100 i'm waiting you know
over this uh lockdown i spoken to many
brothers across the
pond so i'm getting to see my american
people my canadian people
uh hopefully we can do something you're
going to be our personal guest
hi brother hi guys before
let's all do it at the same time come on
that's what we're doing here
gotta go to plug in the hashtag bro you
guys made it this far hashtag dollar man
returns
and look forward to part two insha'allah
any final words from you guys guys if
you if you made it this far bro
don't don't don't just like we're not
telling you we want you to like your
like a video bro just because we need
you to like our video bro
it's these types of videos that like
people need to watch and we need to have
the algorithm so
like the video comment share it down
below and yeah
barakallah feed to brother imran for
making the time bro
with that being said everybody watching
[Music]
the reminder is that no matter where you
are in life you know you don't know
where you're gonna be tomorrow
you could be feeling amazing one day and
then literally lose your iman like that
right the prophet of the senate said
that there will come a time where a
person is a believer in the morning
and at night they're a disbeliever
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
hmm